[Music]
all right george let's talk inflation
shall we yes so we took a call earlier
uh about housing and it's a stressful
thing for a lot of people combating
inflation protecting your four walls and
so we've been doing a series on this
we've covered food and utilities we've
got those highlights on our youtube
channel for you to go check out and
today i want to talk about housing this
is a big issue whether you're renting or
you're looking to buy a house this is a
tough situation for a lot of people
we're seeing prices ballooning out of
control right now i mean we're seeing
some stats here rent has ballooned 20
since january 2021 we're seeing them be
much higher elsewhere 50 percent even 60
percent some areas with rent so let's
talk about ways to save on rent number
one this is uncomfortable no one wants
to do it get a roommate
i know you don't want to live with other
people people are complicated you want
to have your own space you don't want to
deal with the dishes sitting in the sink
but
that person can cut your housing
expenses in half
and this can be a great temporary short
gap to get you to where you want to be
financially number two sign a longer
lease a lot of the times if you sign a
longer lease if you know you're going to
stay in the same place for a while you
can sign a 16 monthly it's an 18 month
lease and save some money that way and
lastly this is a crazy one
you can move out you can go find cheaper
rent elsewhere and it may mean moving
out of the fancy city and you're a
little further out
but if you can stomach the commute or if
you're a remote man that opens you up to
a lot of options when it comes to rent
do that now when it comes to buying a
house this is a big one ken people are
making some really terrible decisions
out there because of the fomo and the
market and they feel like if they don't
get in now they'll never get in now what
is the fomo george the fomo is the
housing prices are going up so fast that
i'll never be able to save up so why not
just do it now
even though i can't afford the mortgage
i'm just going to go ahead and do it and
worry about it later and i can tell you
we take plenty of calls here on the
ramsay show of people who call in and
say ken george i made a huge mistake we
jumped into a house too soon because we
were impulsive we skipped the appraisal
we skipped the inspection it's got the
roof is caving in which needs 20k of
work
and we don't know what to do and the
mortgage payment is we can't breathe
with this payment so i want you to buy a
house the right way and that means
saving money because you're not going to
be drowning so here's how to save on
housing number one save up 10 to 20
for your down payment and i want you to
avoid pmi that's private mortgage
insurance if you can put 20 down or more
which is money that protects the banks
not you
in case you can't pay
number two i want your your payment to
be no more than 25
of your monthly take-home pay on a
15-year fixed uh loan now that's hard
for a lot of people they go well come on
ken it's going to take me seven years to
get there i'm fine with that if it means
you're not broke for the next seven
years because you had no patience to
wait yeah and third this goes right into
this wait until the market cools down
we're seeing interest rates start to go
up which hopefully helps cool off the
market i'm not going to predict anything
but that's the hope so let's chill out
let's be patient let's take this time to
save up even more for the down payment
so that when it cools down we can make a
level-headed decision i got a thought
george you were talking about fomo and
uh fear of missing out is what you're
talking about i think it needs to be
foso fear of stressed out oh i like that
that's not good at all well that's not
good i want you all to check out the
full blog at ramseysolutions.com it's
called how to combat inflation and
protect your four walls we cover
everything from food utilities housing
transportation i think even if you do a
few of these ideas it will help create
some margin in your budget so that you
can breathe so that we can get through
this crazy time of